did you ever wonder if your TV set is
jealous of the time you spend watching
web video well I say let it suffer
television has certainly made me suffer
a lot this year I'm here to tell you
about the top 5 most frustrating TV
moments of 2014 in this week's episode
of angry nerd first let's go to the
mailbag in a previous episode I asked if
you'd like to see Disney characters
wreck-it Ralph and baymax added to
Disney's fairytale mashup once upon a
time your overwhelming answer was yes
several of you proposed a
once-upon-a-time Kingdom Hearts spin-off
I would so watch that one of you
proposed a Tron wreck-it Ralph crossover
called once upon a grid we need to make
this happen now let's talk about the
most frustrating TV moments of 2014
doctor who usually spent some time in
the first episode after a regeneration
helping fans get acclimated to the new
doctor shush but the first episode of
this season went to absolutely
ridiculous lengths to handhold and scold
me for any resistance to dr. number 12
one character even lectured another
character about accepting this new
doctor a lecture that was clearly
intended for the viewing audience he
looked like your dashing young gentleman
friend your lover even shut up but
here's the doctor and then the topper
Matt Smith did a cameo to command that
viewers accept Capaldi and I never scare
you all are the man you won't win right
now believe me he is more scared than
anything you could imagine right now see
I was totally open to this Capaldi guy
before that scene but this endless
hectoring made me want to dislike the
new who on principle alone Oh doctor who
season 8 episode 1 you were less subtle
than then the pilot of Gotham what's
nowhere but everywhere except for
something is you know what I suspect
that guy might turn out to be the
riddler now Shonda Rhimes is a genius
who a single handedly saved live
television
and watching her new show how to get
away with murder is like dumpster diving
at the Rockefellers house it's the most
high-grade trash you will ever consume
but it's hard for me to savor this
guilty pleasure when ABC is helpfully
superimposing hashtags and urging me to
tweet in every intro and commercial
break and teaser for next week's episode
your jaw will hit the floor defilement
get to it you obedience she tweet about
your viewing experience OMG you should
be using our hashtag tgit or last nine
words or who killed Sam keep hitting
refresh Viola Davis is live tweeting now
I get that this is part of the viewing
experience now but if I'm going to be
part of ABC's marketing department I
want a paycheck and while i'm talking
about how to get away with murder let me
add that it's an example of the lamest
trend on TV this year shows about women
with immensely successful professional
lives and disastrous personal lives now
TV has been telling gals that they can't
have it all for five decades but two of
the worst new shows on TV this year take
this trend to malignant new depths one
was bad judge which portrays a
tough-as-nails judge who's a reckless
party girl when she's off the clock the
other mysteries of laura is about a
detective and single mom and it seems to
have been written by people from another
planet with no insight into single
motherhood or humanity in general this
is a depraved unspeakable act get ready
to be inside for very long
sorry mommy these shows are a crime
against the audience and a crime against
two of the most appealing lead actors on
television now selfie sounded like the
lamest thing ever when it was announced
a social media twist on Pygmalion oh how
do you do mrs. Higgins how are you TBH
that premise does not make me LOL hey if
you agree RT if you disagree but then
the show turned out to be not bad
slightly better than I expected and of
course of course as soon as I resolve to
watch it it got cancelled Oh TV gods why
have you forsaken your most loyal of
oils in September the CW killed the last
remaining block of cartoons that aired
on Saturday mornings this is an outrage
and no I'm not just a nostalgic gen Xer
pining for the days when I would watch
captain n and my fede pajamas with a
bowl of fruit loops in my lap because I
just did that less Wednesday I know that
there's an endless catalogue of cartoons
on netflix but Saturday morning cartoons
had a sense of occasion to them you were
watching the premiere kid-focused
intellectual properties in the land
won't someone think of the children oh I
forgot it was disgraceful how
Nickelodeon unceremoniously dumped
Legend of Korra midway through the third
season no show has been treated this
badly by a network since Firefly wasn't
that loss at Zoe and a kind of poetry to
it sir the cancellation of Korra was
also bad for the tradition of geek
friendly shows on prime time on Friday
night or as i call it the x-files slot
only Grimm and Constantine remain at
this point and frankly things look grim
for Constantine what do you think of
legend of korra what do you think about
staying home Friday night to watch geeky
TV what are your most favorite and least
favorite TV moments of 2014 let me know
in the comments and subscribe to the
wired channel